Now I will argue that these
enhanced Multitape Turing machines
have the same computational power
as regular Turing machines.
Multitape machines certainly
don't have less power.
By ignoring all but the input tape,
we obtain a regular Turing machine.
Let's see why Multitape Turing
machines don't have any more power
than regular machines.
On the left, we have a Multitape Turing
machine in some configuration.
And on the right, we have created
a corresponding configuration for
a single tape Turing machine.
On the single tape, we have
the contents of the multiple tapes
with each tape's contents
separated by a hash.
So here's the first tape, here's
the second tape, here's the third tape.
Also note these dots here.
We're using a trick that
we haven't used before,
expanding the size of the alphabet.
For every symbol in the tape
alphabet of the multitape machine,
we have two symbols on
the single tape machine.
One with a dot, and one without.
We use the mark symbols to indicate
that the head of the multitape machine
would be over this position on the tape.
So the 1 is marked here, the 1 is
marked here, and the 0 is marked here.
Simulating a step of the multitape
machine with the single tape version
happens in two phases, one for
reading and one for writing.
First, the single tape machine simulates
the simultaneous reading of
the heads of the multitape machine.
By scanning over the input and
noting which symbols have marks on them.
So here it would first note that one
is under the head of the first tape,
then that another one is under
the head of the second tape.
And then that a 0 is under
the head of the third tape.
That completes the first phase
where we read the symbols.
Now I need to update
the tape contents and
the head positions or
markers as part of the writing phase.
Let's say that the multitape
machine changes this 0 to a 1 and
moves the head to the left, like so.
Then on the single tape machine,
we need to change this 0 dot to a 1 and
change this 0 to a 0 dot.
Note that it's possible that one of
these strings will need to increase its
length when the multitape writes to
a position it hasn't reached before.
In that case, we just right shift
the tape contents to allow room for
the new symbol to be written.
Once all that work is done,
we return the head back to the beginning
to prepare for the next path, like so.
And notice that I updated
the tape contents appropriately.
So all the information about
the configuration of a multitape machine
can be captured in a single tape.
And it's not too hard to convince
yourself that all the logic needed
to read from multiple places and
remember all that contents.
In order to figure out
the right writing response,
can also be implemented with
a state transition logic.
It's a good exercise to work that
out if it's not obvious to you.